not really I knew a little bit about
Formula one but I was never a huge fan
and not because I'd made some conscious
decision not to be it was just not in my
circle so I've got friends growing up
but read a lot of books on James Hunt
spoke to a lot of people who knew him
and they'd race with him and watch the
world internet interviews and clippings
and BBC gave us a whole bunch of
interviews and outtakes and be wrong
which was which was the most informative
stuff because it was him just playing
around and riffing and the off-camera
assad's which gives the most insight
into who he was
yes sir no I mean there's the
similarities in the and that you know
you put in the same amount of work and
you want to find a way in to empathize
with that character but deplane James
Hunt was certainly was a much different
opportunity a much different experience
to anything I've had before because it
was I was playing a real-life person an
icon there was a lot of anxiety to do
him justice and respectful portrayal
there was a book called Armageddon's
children by Terry Brooks which was a
fantasy novel and sort of a
post-apocalyptic world and there was a
character in there called Logan it was
pretty impressive very impressive gonna
see as a warrior
that old futuristic and fascinating
books